yeah and then so are you done with crazy
rich people crazy rich people yeah in
Asia for two and a half months and not
like what East Asia Southeast Asia I was
when I was in South the urine was in
Malaysia I was in Malaysia for a month
and a half I you know
Malaysia is a great country people
they're like great very warm very like
like you know they want to help you they
like people but what was I gonna say I
was I gonna end that what what is it
about is there anything negative about
Malaysia oh when I saw the Malaysian
airline plane round twice in a row I was
I was thinking to myself like oh thank
god I'll never ride that airline because
I'll never go to Malaysia I rode that
[ __ ] air so many times like little
trips yeah and like and like any time
the the plane did something or the
flight attendant came by you know yeah
you guys are gonna die oh wow wow so I
shot a movie in Thailand once for two
months mm-hm
the worst is this when they go you have
four days off but you can't go back to
New York Lee exactly so there what the
[ __ ] so then you start wandering the
streets in this heat yeah it's not
Florida heat it's not Texas heat it's
like Oh wet it's that he was equatorial
yeah and then you there you go I'm
hungry
yeah and then you see like a stand with
meat hanging yeah right in the hand
there's this flies and you know mean and
yeah we're eating it you're like
grossest restaurant I think I want to I
mean everything was pretty fine in
Malaysia actually is like it's a little
Kuala Lumpur the legit city they have
like more Louie Vuitton stores and then
like Starbucks in New York yeah but like
there's one store and it just smelled
like um like a like a like a adoption a
dog adoption center
in Malaysia they have this this like
health guideline where you have to wear
like a spit shield yeah so it's like a
little shield but it's a clear shield
like a visor oh wow and you can see the
spittle on the thing it's like it's
almost more disgusting if you don't wear
it it didn't get much I mean it was it
was fine I'm just being an agent so you
never got any diarrhea um may maybe like
maybe constipation maybe maybe I when I
went for about like four and half weeks
yeah I had an audition for that I never
showed up to it for your family yeah I
don't remember I went it was a lot of
Lies for my dad I came John I don't know
lines and I went no I can't do yeah but
I think as a Korean on that set there is
an element of feeling like like you're
like a little bit like you shouldn't be
there yeah that's what also it's Chinese
people right that the show the movie
it's it should be Chinese people yeah
but it was a mix of people it was right
hey Cassie right right right I think ken
was the only Korean yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah I think that's also was a
part of it like I'm not gonna get this
so I'd look at him you would have gotten
it dude No thank you man what they gave
the part to Ken cuz you did an audition
I don't think it was for that part oh
you don't think so yeah maybe not I
don't know but um
[Music]